vous pourrez faire c'est une recette ou
en magrets à poil elle qui est là la
poitrine et puis la cuisse à lui ses
petites ici et cuisses plus saine ça
fait quand même suffisamment et ses
patrons
donc on peut s'amuser à faire une aile
avec une depuis son 1er petit peu rosé
de table
les récentes avec une sauce au petit peu
légère aussi et la cuisson la phrase
soit confites soit uni qui sont plus
poussée avec une sauce au plus réduite
aussi ce qui fait que on aura avec un
seul animal une carcasse qui permettra
de faire un bouillon des petits débris
des coûts des petits morceaux de chair
et des de la peau qui permettront de
faire de petits fruits top pour la
salade après viendra la poitrine contre
l'accusé principal
ça c'est un kabar qui n'est pas gaver il
n'y a pas de matière à dessus pas de
palafox un ici parlant des foies gras on
peut dire qu'il ya deux canards qui font
le foie gras les mulard et les barbaries
le muller c'est le digestif
il fait un beau fois bon une fois qu'ils
font pas la cuisson le var varices
l'athlète il a des muscles il a des
maigret d'aimer de bons maigret costaud
sanguin qui ont du goût des cuisses
musclées qui font de bons confie alors
il faut savoir choisir le muller quatre
vols intérieurs le barbe la barbarie
kahn devait l'extérieur c'est tout
simple alors le canard qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure
voilà on a parlé avec un petit couteau
on a on a détaché la chaire de l'os et
puis on en a fait ce manteau c'est à
dire les deux cuisses les deux ailes
avec l'as carcassonne à faire autre
chose tout à l'heure on est celui là
maintenant on va le découper et ça va
donner ça les deux ailes et voilà
les locaux et voilà les petits filets
mignons comme ici et les deux cuisses
solar dans une casserole eau chaude
les cas sont lancés comme les fours il
faut les faire chauffer d'avancer
toujours un peu de beurre au passeport
de pas chauvin mais pas beaucoup
et maintenant on va faire écrire les
clichés d'un côté les ailes de l'autre
puis aller
pour les cuisses même opération
[Musique]
la cuisse va être cuite longtemps
donc il faut que la cuisson soit poussé
gentiment et on va la mettre dans sa
propre rappeur pas les moyens de courir
pour apprécier la cuisson sans le monde
sont ni chronomètre quand on fait comme
ça visiblement c'est entièrement bourg
par conséquent le milieu et mais sachons
apprécier une cuisson après la
consistance la viande si elle est
vraiment c'est bleu bleu pas chaud si
c'est un peu plus de 600 cc ya 6 et
souffle en essayant points et si c'est
dur 10h58 à la pétition portée
astuces de cuisine c'est presque puis on
le met dans une assiette
ouverte par une autre à syrte et on
laisse ça au chaud au chaud mais pas
maintenant très chaud c'est à dire que
les chaleurs sont à partir dans les
chais révolte et les curieux se sont
assez bien et bien au chaud jusqu'au bdl
qui sortent d'une cuisson les verts aux
roses et on va faire une sauce qui sera
distingué une aquarelle on peut alors
voir faire rissoler un petit peu les
faits l'autre juste un peu et chalon
crachez pas trop faible parce que je
trouve qui est ailleurs avançant sous la
dent quand on va goûter la sauce après
on va récupérer cette histoire le dm qui
est là une source au loyer c'est à dire
une avec bordeaux c'est à dire c'est à
dire ça
voilà et maintenant on va laisser ça
réduire par an qui là bas
et ça va nous faire une bonne sauce
extrêmement intéressant on va prendre
les ailes les cuisses et on va finir
leur cuisson au four ce qui nous
permettra de bâtir la sauce déjà on va
toujours pareil mais trompeuse échalotes
passé l'échalote réagit bien sûr une
cassure les choses comme ça sur une
rissoles d'ailleurs le loader qu'elle
dégage intégral mais là on va ajouter
alors un peu de poivre écrasé n'ont pas
voulu et surtout on va y mettre un petit
peu de moutarde et qui va demander
encore extraordinaire à la chanson
voilà la voit petit à petit elle a petit
à petit aussi récupérer la rissole au
bout de six années cuisse alors là
puisqu'il s'agit de puits sont poussés
on va faire une sauce réduite et coloré
aulas même principe réduction ici on est
presque à sec
donc c'est le moment on va mettre un peu
de crème
alors bien sûr il y aura la question
habituelle des ménages heures et qu'ils
ont souhaité la cave au fait vous y avez
mesure non seulement la crème peuvent
rire mais ils doivent rire parce que si
elle vous paraît pas vraiment
[Musique]
à côté
vous pouvez voir qu'on a fait est très
simple des gousses d'ail et du sel du
poivre la graisse d'oie sur le coin du
fourneau ça se fait tout seul sur la
copie c'est à y compris celles offrant
de très jolis garniture sur l'assiette
et puis c'est vrai mais voilà là on est
presque à sec
alors maintenant on prend un petit peu
young lion est tentant de marcher
et avec ça on va se faire une sauce
brune alors ce qui sera studieux cédant
passer une au chinois et pas l'autre
comme ça on aurait deux sauces aux
différences de goûts et de consistance
parce que le toucher est important les
chinois manipule le mieux manie mieux
toucher que nous en cuisine il aime bien
faire d'usure et du monde du show et
l'effroi de et nous on apprend du
croustillant est devenue allemande à
onna on est on a vu le chemin froid le
sucré salé mais le le groupe le toucher
pour burnley on est parlé par contre
c'est la vieillesse il faut approcher la
caméra et on s'aperçoit que on commence
à voir le fond de la casserole à terre
et vu le donnent l'assaut c'est presque
fini
aucune liaison réduction violente d'une
semaine normale sur celle là on va là
lié à la crème il faut attendre que
l'ébullition soit violente et général à
ce pas un tout petit peu de créneaux
mais très peu olam est dans la sauce
on est tout chaud pas
chacun à disparaître tout seul à la
source et en même temps que
disparaissait l'allier elle va pas la
blanchir quand le fléau sera faite là ce
soir là même aux couleurs cavani mettre
la grève mais à condition de ne pas y
toucher
voilà ces projets visent en fait la
première hausse sur l'ale avec les
petits morceaux et chaleureuse à la
deuxième chose avec les championnats où
passent dans la face aux chinois où
l'eau ça c'est une affaire de goût de
reviens quand tu n'es pas passé on la
met sur la cuisse
vu que dans aucune se sont signalés
d'épaississant le liant les deux villes
de farine donc sondé sodigest et qui
sont pas difficiles à faire pour le côté
local pittoresque et savoureux quelques
petites gousses d'ail ce qu'on a fait
confiance dans la grèce doir gentiva
[Musique]
e
je
donc ce menu est un menu qui est facile
à préparer au pire à l'avant ce gratin
de huit ans elle de sa dette
l'eau bouillonne digestifs au milieu
avec si on veut quelques escalopes du
gésier de l'animal qu'on a fait confie
draveil
derrière on met les cuisses puis la
salade avec les petits frites ont chacun
de se faire du fric et derrière le
dessert comme vous à convoyer ce petit
biscuit au gras de canard et voilà on a
venue de réveillon qui sort du même
animal
[Musique]